boostin Bell and Dax Shepard will
celebrate their fifth anniversary next
month and Dax was on the top of
Kristen's mind
on the top of the Empire State Building
he's a Papa Bear he really he jumps to
my defense signal in a lot of ways and
it does it makes me feel very loved
glowing with pride for husband Dax but
the OS headed Kristen admits while her
marriage is tight she's got her share of
Hollywood crushes how much time do you
have I mean I have like notable ones of
a big crush on Riz Ahmed you know I
loved Keith Morrison Vincent D'Onofrio I
mean I could go I truly could go out for
days I once got 12 out of 12 on a
BuzzFeed quiz called do you know all the
slang words the Kardashians invented
congratulation thank you I'm gonna be
honest I did cheat
tonight Kristin's NBC comedy the good
place premieres its third season but
it's the Halloween season this really
got this mama stressed Halloween is huge
it's one of my favorite holidays what do
you want to hear something that I think
is so lame my kids want to be exactly
what they were last year and I'm like
what but I mean I can't tell them they
can't want it um so yeah I guess we're
just dusted off last year's costumes
today Kristen lit up the Empire State
Building in support of the women's peace
and humanitarian fund Kristen hopes her
daughters see how women can empower
change I'm hoping to teach them that
they they have valued shareable ideas
that are worthy of being heard I love
how she uses her star power for good in
so many ways it's so many
[Music]